I'm actually seeing one or two rap
survival things so I think I got this
today in Sony Pictures the shallows
Blake Lively is stranded on a rock
fighting a big ass shark so we're gonna
be stranded in a raft with no food no
water and no crew which means we're
gonna be stuck alone with each other
which is literally my worst nightmare
we're gonna simulate an ocean disaster
situation today what advice do you have
for us stay calm
the first thing is to leave the boat
it's just the ocean there's nothing in
it here we go oh my god this is the
worst feeling in the world I hate this
and then I hate this your life raft is
attached to your boat with what's called
a painter line you jerk on that that
inflates what kind of emergency stuff is
in the round and you will have flares I
want to have a mirror mirror to make
sure that Eugene's hair still looks good
what should we do once we get on the
raft fine duty now what if one of us has
no talents then your unbale duty fail it
over the rap not back into the rep it
sounds boring it is boring it's you in
the elements you're gonna get seasick
water and water the most humiliating
experience alright the Sun is really
beating down will you stop with the day
logs Ned please shut up I'm gonna puke
on you we suck at this we have shark
where's that crazy did I see it that's a
shark that is a shark right there right
there right under us wall don't panic
don't panic stay calm don't throw up in
shark-infested waters really real I got
something to say what are you guys being
stick and in such a terrible environment
this is such a horrible thing
the boat let's great [ __ ] job Ned so
there's a shark who's uh I think there's
a shark that's been circling us
the orange how long can we expect to
survive in a white jacket 24 hours 30
hours gentlemen it's been a pleasure and
an honor
well we just got royally by the ocean
yeah that wasn't jittery of the worst
experience of my life ever
I got dehydrated immediately by vomiting
everything out I was essentially dead or
doomed
Eugene Annette argued a lot about who is
the captain I think Zack was the captain
I was not expecting sharks to be there
the last thing I wanted to do when I was
looking down at the sharks 10 feet under
us was I don't know hang out with it
live too late to not swim with sharks
tomorrow
that was our goddamn nightmare so check
out so many pictures of shallows